Hey youtubers it’s charlie, this is going
to be my first Last Airbender video.
So many of you requested videos for the original
series that I thought it would be a fun way
to be less depressed after the Korra finale.
Originally I was going to start by doing a
video for the first episode but I thought
doing a prologue and an examination of the
unaired pilot would be
a better way to start.
Even if you know all the episodes by heart,
think of this as a chance to focus on specific
things in each episode.
Sometimes you miss a lot of things when you
try to remember details and you haven’t
watched a show in a long time.
It’s like re-watching The Wire on HBO right
now.
Or even the classic simpsons episodes.
I haven’t completely figured out what the
schedule for these avatar videos will be but
be sure to subscribe to get everything and
dig your episode links out of your bookmarks.
Just for fun I’ll say careful for spoilers.
Maybe some of you haven’t seen last airbender
before.
Welcome to the fandom!
Bryan and Mike pitched Avatar The Last Airbender
to an acquaintance at Nickelodeon in that
period right after Fellowship of the Ring
and the first Harry Potter had come out.
The pitch for what would become Last Airbender
was made in 2001.
The series didn’t debut till 2005.
Just to give you an idea for how long it took
to get through the production process.
The two of them weren’t officially known
as Bryke before working on Last Airbender.
They went to college together at the Rhode
Island School of Design.
That’s where they met.
And they did work on most of the same shows
like Family Guy when it first started, King
of The Hill, Mission Hill and Invader Zim
were the last things they did before Avatar.
But they usually worked in different departments
on each of those shows.
Bryan spent most of his time working on storyboards
and character design.
And Michael usually worked as an animation
director.
There were both storyboard artists on King
of The Hill though.
They talk a little about it here in this clip.
Bryan said that he hated working on King of
the Hill so much he almost quit Hollywood
animation and went to Pixar.
The funny thing is that they said the original
show they were going to pitch to Nick was
completely different from Avatar.
Bryan said it was something you would expect
to see on Nickelodeon.
Something that looked and felt like it came
from them, but worked more with spongebob
type programming.
He’s never explained what that show was
supposed to be because they still might pitch
it at some point.
So that actually might end up being the next
tv show they produce, even if it’s with
another network like dreamworks animation.
Most of
what
they talk about when they talk about creating
avatar is
the original proof of concept.
Bryan’s original sketch for Aang and Appa
and the overseas Korean Animators.
Bryan is the one who spends most of his time
working with them.
The original overseas animation director on
Avatar, Jae-Myung Yu, this guy right here
was able to create Studio Miir specifically
for Legend of Korra.
When it came time to make Legend Of Korra,
because Nick had ordered all the book 1 episodes
up front, Team Bryke had the money to hire
an animation studio.
They wanted Yu to do the series, but he was
working somewhere else.
So he left to create Studio Miir and they
did the episodes.
Since then they’ve grown as a korean animation
studio and worked on other series.
And they have a big deal they just signed
with Dreamworks animation for new shows they’re
working on but they’re not avatar shows.
But just to be clear, Studio Miir and Team
Bryke are two separate entities, they don’t
have any ownership in Studio Miir.
DR Studio were the animators on Last Airbender.
They mostly do anime productions but they’ve
also done a lot of hollywood stuff like some
of the DC and Marvel animated movies and other
Nickelodeon stuff.
Jeremy Zuckerman and Bejamin Wynn did all
the music, as they did for Legend of Korra.
But just like with Studio Miir, because of
the work they did on the Original Avatar Series,
they were able to create their own production
company called The Track Team.
They score other hollywood stuff, but it’s
cool to know that Avatar was able to give
rise to all these new studios.
Sometimes that will happen on bigger shows
and movies.
A few people land a deal for a new show, and
build a team around them to make it.
And each of the departments build teams around
them.
The very first episode they ever produced
was the unaired pilot.
They changed a lot of the story before they
aired the first official episode on February
1st, 2005.
The pilot was only about 15 minutes long,
here’s a breakdown of the stuff they ended
up changing:
The four images shown in the opening sequence
of Aang bending do not follow the order of
the Avatar Cycle.
Instead, they go from air, to water, followed
by fire, and ending with earth.
There are several bending techniques used
that were not seen in the polished show, such
as the group-fireball created by Zuko and
several of his soldiers.
The concept of the Avatar State functioning
as a defense mechanism was similar to its
concept in the main series, though in the
pilot, Aang would purposely put himself in
danger to enter it.
The creators later felt that the concept of
the Avatar State needed to be more complex,
and so, in the series, they initially gave
Aang no control over it, requiring him to
be in genuine danger before he would enter
the state.
Many aspects of the original pilot were later
incorporated into the actual series but in
different fashions:
The serpent that attacked Team Avatar, and
later Zuko's ship, was recycled in "The Serpent's
Pass" and "The Awakening".
The Fire Nation soldier armor design
is significantly different from the original
series' primary design but an earlier Fire
Nation armor seen in "The Southern Air Temple"
and "The Siege of the North, Part 1" share
similarities to the original design.
Zuko and Aang's scaffolding battle was re-used
in "Return to Omashu" during Aang's fight
with Azula.
Zuko's messenger hawk chasing Momo was recycled
in "The Waterbending Scroll" where the pirate
captain's iguana parrot chased Momo and in
"The Runaway" where Momo and Hawky do not
get along.
Aang saving Zuko at the last minute was recycled
in "The Blue Spirit" and "The Siege of the
North, Part 2".
Sokka saving himself and Kya by tossing his
boomerang attached to a rope to Aang as he
flew over on his glider was re-used in "The
Northern Air Temple" though there Sokka saved
himself and the mechanist.
Although Kya is renamed Katara, her "original"
name is recycled as the names for both her
mother anddaughter.
As Aang airbends in the opening sequence,
a statue of a lion turtle can be seen.
While the early concept of Pakku waterbends
in the opening sequence, the Northern Water
Tribe in the background looks more like a
castle than how it is depicted in the final
version.
The prototype of Toph seen in the opening
sequence was later recycled as The Boulder,
Sud, and Bolin.
Next video - epsiode 1 - schedule - when to
watch.
favorite things to pick out.
- probably saturdays, doesn’t mean I won’t
do other anime series.